another one of my obsessions one of the
things I was so struck by reading the
books of getting into them was how much
and this to me was unique in the fantasy
that I was reading all I've ever read is
is the overriding concern of parents and
children their parents and children's
throughout in fact I had this idea after
meeting Game of Thrones that you could
do a tie-in book called Rob not ja
parenting the Game of Thrones way but it
is true people are so influenced by
their parents how well they were raised
how poorly they were raised you don't
have children where do you get your
seeming to me very profound insights
into parenting and children and help
children relate to their parents in
vice-versa
I don't know you do draw on your own
upbringing and the course one thing you
read and things that you see see around
you I mean that parenting is a
fascinating issue you know I suppose
it's true that I had certain issues with
my own father and maybe some of those
being reflected in the variety of people
in in the books that have father issues
although my father issues were never
like where you get any of this stuff
that's it sometimes it's hard to know
but it's an important it's an important
issue and one thing that you one thing
you really really read about again if
you read Middle Ages the history of the
real Middle Ages and and even Rome and
other things is it least it was all
about families they're their primary
loyalty we don't need to the family not
to not to the society or or you know
some concept I mean nationalism was a
later concept
you know when we read about the the
Hundred Years War you know we think of
it looking at the modern viewpoint it
was a war between France and England
well no not really not really it was a
there was a war between two branches of
the same dynasty that we're competing
you know that the descendants of of the
completion dynasty you know against the
Valois dynasty which was trying to come
in in which day was cousins fighting
each other in some ways not unlike the
Starks and the Lannisters or the York's
and the Lancaster's in the later of wars
of the roses so a lot of these things
were families I'll tell you that I
myself as a father which is a mistake
you know I bet if you guys well it's
interesting
just to be serious and you know glum
about the funny thing I just talked
about I think we got it too is the whole
issue of the whole like the Catholic are
not going against the Sultan or the
parent kids not you know we're just
having this huge influence of the
parents to meet with really resonates in
your work to is that people are torn
between what they know and the fear of
the unknown and you might have a
terrible stepfather or father or counsel
that you're living in or situation that
you're in but you know that situation
you know that city
know that place and what you don't know
is more terrifying and I think that
that's one of the most useful devices
that are you know situated things that
you do and the stories I think this TV
show reflects does is that you know
people are torn between the bad known
choice and the unknown possibly
horriffic choice there's no really oh
but here's the here's the great choice
which will be wonderful and everything
will work out there isn't that but is
that an idea that really resonates for
you as a writer just the fear of the
unknown and people clinging on to what
they do know even if it's not great well
certainly in the question of people
making choices you know interests me you
know why people do make the choices that
they that they they make I mean I've
always quoted as one of my guiding
principles as writer Faulkner's the
Nobel Prize acceptance speech where he
said that the only thing worth writing
about was a human heart in conflict with
itself and and I think there's a great
deal of truth to that we talk about
science fiction sort of ideas and
fantasies or their imagination and
little ideas about imagination but still
ultimately it comes down to characters
and it comes down to them and the human
heart in conflict with itself and us
making these these difficult decisions
in difficult situations I mean I was
talking about this with a friend who has
a young daughter just a couple days ago
and you know the whole question of
beginning with Jamie and Brian you know
obviously a lot of people when when
Jamie throws bran out the the window and
we like bran we've seen the waiter we
tend to think that makes Jamie a bad guy
okay but then you understand if you
understand the situation if Brando's
and that was what he saw and he's
believed Jamie will be put to death his
sister will be put to death in this
excellent chance that his only children
will be put to death
so I said to my friend okay what would
what would you do if some other
eight-year-old kid you know was in a
position to say something and you knew
that would mean the death of your own
young daughter and he said that is their
moral man so how do you make that choice
you know if they have stricter morality
versus the lives of your own children I
mean you know they might mean I don't
know that I'm approximate Iser who says
this is the answer to that I mean that
what I the question a painful difficult
question that the difficulty of the
choice that's that's what I think makes
powerful fiction yeah I mean that's
that's why I think one of the things I
certainly respond to is this idea that
oh there was the structured society and
everyone kind of knew what
stratification they were at that's an
appealing concept or that there's a
family you know what the role of the
parents are you know what the role of
the kids are and how they're going to
respond but then there are these things
that come along that put you in conflict
and one of the things that's great about
the books is that there are you might
have a allegiance to your house to your
family to your sibling to your parent
but is in conflict with your allegiance
to your army or some other group that
you're part of I mean that's that's not
even a question I'm just rambling yeah
but that's that's a great way that you
mark the books with these choices that
really are you know at some point
someone something bad will happen no
matter what you choose what makes for
good reading